anybody watching go look at any money
book look at chapter one you know what
they tell you to do in Chapter one of
any book takes hard work years of hard
work the idea of working hard is silly
it's silly you need to stop thinking
like this if you ever want to get ahead
financially if you ever want to be
successful if you want to be rich want
to be happy
build a life not just the business hate
7 Carmichael and this channel was
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you to you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how money really works
and why you won't get rich just by
working hard ok let's kick it off with
rule number one define what you want
with ramita safety we grow up with these
things I call invisible scripts and
these are the scripts that are beliefs
that are so powerful we don't even
realize that they're there around us
that's why they're invisible so a
classic one in America is the American
Dream is buying a house where did that
come from
and in fact there's all these phrases
that people use like you're throwing
money away on rent
they don't make more land you know and
on on and on if you really deconstruct
that and you actually run the numbers
you might discover that actually buying
a house is often not the best investment
and this is super counter into it really
mad because real estate is religion in
America but if you actually dot dive in
deep you might discover wow there's a
lot of parties who want me to spend a
ton of money that's why for example I
could buy today but I rent and what
people hear that they're like wait I
thought I will teach you to be rich guys
Ridge so why is it ready they get very
confused because real estate is religion
you know another thing that is really
common today for people is there's no
way to get ahead right especially for
young people social security won't be
around etc etc and I just don't believe
in that I think if you go on to read it
or you go on to these places where it's
a it's a lot of people who are
disaffected young people they create an
echo chamber of other people who want to
victimize themselves then you have a
choice do you want to be reading those
threads or like I was reading the
comments on your youtube videos I was
like these are the best youtube comments
I've ever seen people are positive
constructive they're pointing out things
they saw in the 30 second minute of the
video meaning they actually watch the
whole thing those are the kind of people
that I want people to be around
so it's not impossible to make money
there's actually a lot of people making
money it's not impossible to get ahead
pay off debt even invest and grow
there's a lot of people doing it but if
you're surrounded by people who
constantly complain about how difficult
it is and it's impossible guess what
you're gonna absorb those invisible
scripts I had a woman who wrote me and
she said roommate can you help me
convince my husband not to waste money
and I go okay what what's going on she
goes he spent so much money on iced tea
and I was like here we go I go how much
money
and she goes he buys iced tea 20 times a
month like almost every day I said how
much is this iced tea she said it's a
dollar fifty each time so in my head I'm
like this is insane like why are we even
talking about this iron but I knew
there's something here so I want to
unpack it
I said out of curiosity what's your
household income no response for 20
minutes okay and then finally she comes
back she goes I'm not comfortable
sharing that I said just give me a range
okay what do you think her her and her
husband's household income is I know the
story I I would have guessed otherwise
would 80,000 and 100,000 like a nice six
hundred thousand and the this is a
perfect example like rationally and
logically we should literally not be
talking about this because it's a
rounding error but there's something
going on in her belief system that made
her fixate on iced
and so for anybody whether it's ice-t or
whether it's you know lattes is a
classic example everybody tells you not
spend money I'm like that's the worst
advice ever buy as many lattes as you
want or some people they just love for
example clothes right I like clothes
they love it but everybody around them
has told them things like that's shallow
that's a waste of money you should
invest in your Roth IRA and so what do
they do all of us we're torn apart
because we live in a paradoxical society
that is both puritanical telling us we
should retreat into a cave and do
nothing but then we go on Instagram and
everyone's in Bora Bora it's ridiculous
and so what do we do we just buy
everything and then we feel guilty it's
the worst possible response so what I do
is first I say what do you love spending
money on love and nobody talks about
this they always say well let me see
your budget your overspending and
everyone's just like a half forget this
I'll never come on here and talk berate
someone for their spending because I've
seen it all when they talk about what
they love then I say what would it feel
like to be able to spend two times or
four times as much on them people have
never thought like that then once we
start from a place of aspiration of what
do we want let's work through the
mechanics of how to get there really
fast to find a rich life for people
because I think that's gonna be a key
component yeah this whole discussion
well it's different for everyone my rich
life early on was to be able to go to a
restaurant and order appetizers because
I never did it when I was a kid at it
like ever we would go and we'd eat up
once every four to six weeks if we had a
coupon and we would like share two cokes
with the whole family and we would never
order appetizers so I was like I'm gonna
do it and then the next dream for me was
to be able to hop in a taxi if I lived
in New York during the summer without
having to take the train and sweat
before a meeting now my dreams got
bigger and there's a variety of things
that are my rich life but everybody's is
different so some people I have people
in my book they're like I used your book
my wife and I retired at 35 and 36 we
drive around in an RV I don't want to
drive around in an RV but he and his
wife do and I love that so a rich life
is what you define and when I ask people
what's a rich life to you they usually
say two things
freedom two
very nice word but it's kind of generic
and they say a number usually a million
bucks and I say it like freedom what is
what is that to you and they're like I
want to do whatever I want when I want
and I'm like get specific you want to
order appetizers do you want to do yoga
at 3 p.m. and that's where the
conversation stops so if you're watching
I want everyone to think what is your
rich life and take it from the clouds to
the street I want to buy three different
Lululemon tank tops a month because I
don't ever want to have to wear an old
one whatever go as crazy as you want I
want to take travel for a month and I
want to bring my family with me great a
rich life is different for everyone but
is about your definition most of what
you see with money is just this
mathematical logical stuff and it sounds
good and everyone's like oh yeah
compound interest but then they go back
to their day-to-day life which is like I
want that sweater I know I should be
doing this how come I'm not doing that
I feel bad close the book forget it and
I want to take a really different
approach a perfect example is if you
look at any money book anybody watching
go look at any money book look at
chapter one you know what they tell you
to do in Chapter one of any book fine
let's find out how much you spent last
month and people are like no thanks see
you later they don't know how much they
spent but they know it was bad right and
so if you actually understand human
psychology you know that my goal is not
to make you feel bad my goal is actually
to show you how money can be positive
how you can live a rich life whatever
you want so in Chapter one of my book I
said look we all use credit cards
we all suck at using credit cards and we
all hate credit cards let me show you
how to beat them read these words off
the page this battle-tested script and
you'll get your fees refunded and you'll
get all these perks you don't even know
about people did they're like I don't
know this Indian guys kind of weird I'll
try it they pick up the phone even
Millennials who are afraid of using the
phone they picked up the phone they did
it and they're like oh they're talking
they call the bank called the [ __ ]
rapist yes and like that they get a $35
fee refunded or they get some perk they
never even knew existed and suddenly
psychologically they go oh my god
I can take control of my money it's not
all these huge
snaps of retirement inheritance and all
this stuff nope I called I got money
back now I can do it so it's so
important to be to be really
incorporating your own psychology when
you think about money and part of that
is what do I want where did I get these
beliefs from whether it's a movie or a
family friend and then what can I do
today to start moving along and
developing my rich life also if you want
to have more motivation confidence and
self-love check out my to 54 series
they're free the link to join under
description but now all things are
possible if you believe I was reminded
this morning of a question I'm often
asked how do you eliminate fear from
your life that's a problem with young
people you're not good at anything oh
I'm so good no tell me the truth you're
not good at anything
rule number two hard work is not the
answer with Bob Proctor have you ever
asked yourself why we think we have to
work hard if we're gonna win takes hard
work years of hard work it's not good
information in fact it's a lie
stop and think of some of the people you
know that have been working real hard
for a long time and they're not winning
at all they're broke they're renting a
place to live they don't own their own
home
they're probably driving a used car now
so if they say that dog won't hunt the
idea of working hard is silly
it's silly listen I want you to think of
what this book is this Napoleon Hills
book Think and Grow Rich he writes in
here there are 30 major causes of
failure there's 13 principles of success
now listen to this he said if you are
one of those people who believe that
hard work and honesty alone will bring
riches carries forethought because it is
not true riches when they come in huge
quantities are never the result of hard
work you see look at see this stuff here
no but that's paper we call it money
money is an idea money goes where it's
invited and it stays where it's welcome
the idea that you have to work hard for
this stuff it's not true some of the
people who worked the hardest are the
ones that are in the least now think
about it I was reading where Taylor
Swift young gal singer was the highest
paid entertainer last year she's doing
what she absolutely loves that's not
hard work I get very well paid I'm doing
what I absolutely love the idea that you
have to work hard is silly when you love
what you're doing you'll never work
again see I see work is something that
you're doing that you don't enjoy and
you don't want to do and takes a lot of
energy think this man spent the broke
this book spent his entire life studying
500 the world's most successful people
he became intimate friends with people
like Henry Ford and Thomas Edison Harvey
Firestone became intimate friends with
them they were doing what they
absolutely loved they changed the whole
world Ford put us on wheels
Edison eliminated the place they were
doing what they love and they earned
millions what do you love doing quit
working and start doing with your love
and you'll never work again and you
think about that for a while
and rule number three the last one
before our very special bonus clip is
work on the roots with Dan Locke have
you ever wonder why you worked a very
hard yet you don't get ahead financially
I remember when I was 18 19 years old
that I was hustling and trying to do
side jobs and try to turn to make a
living trying to support my mom but I
could never get ahead financially I was
desperate for money I wanted to make
more money to be able to provide for my
family but I could never get ahead and I
realized that there is something in my
belief system back then there was
holding me back so you need to stop
thinking like this if you ever want to
get ahead financially if you ever want
to be successful if you want to be rich
you see money it's a very interesting
thing money doesn't go to the people who
are desperate for it that it's not it's
not enough to say I want to make more
money that all I want to increase my
income that I want to pay off that debt
that's not enough right if you want to
make more money money earn is a
byproduct of value creation so at the
time I wanted to make more money but I
couldn't make more money because I
wasn't upgrading my excuses if you want
to make a million dollars soft a million
dollar problem right if you want to make
a hundred million dollars soft a hundred
million dollar problems right so don't
chase money chase problems what are some
of the problems that in the marketplace
that you could solve maybe only you
kiss-off that you could bring to the
marketplace your unique skills your
expertise and your talents you bring it
out there right these soft people's
problems or you see a need in the
marketplace that's not being fulfilled
your product your service your brand
that could fulfill that need better than
anybody else you can also make more
money it's not enough just to sit around
and hope that things would change the
hope that you'll make more money that
hope things will turn around you need to
be proactive about it I wanted you to
think about money I say a money tree and
most people want to have more fruit they
want to have better fruit and they look
at that tree look at the money tree and
say I'm not making up money it's no
different than they say you look at that
fruit is eight
I don't like how it tastes it's bitter
it's small as strive it doesn't taste
good it's not sweet right and they
complain and they act like a victim and
you don't like the fruit but if you
don't like the food looking at a foot
and complaining about it that's not
gonna solve the problem what do you need
to do comment below you need to look at
the roots what it's causing this money's
a result it's not a cause it's an effect
what's the cost and effect relationship
what do you need to do to create and
produce better fruit you need to nurture
the tree right you need to plan the seed
if you have not even planted a seed how
can you expect to have a foot pro tree
right the produce foot that you want you
can't what is death seed taking an
action taking their first initial step
upgrading your skill learning how to
deliver more value now you may be saying
well but then how do I do that how do I
deliver more value to people I'm just
doing what I'm doing them I'm going to
school I just have a dead-end job that's
the problem you're looking at the fruit
you're looking at the route you look at
the food you don't like the fruit first
you got to change the foods right you
look at most like big tall trees what do
they have there's a very good strong
foundation they have a very strong root
system that's the foundation piece
that's something that you could change
there's something that you can work on
yourself and get better
so don't complain and say hey how come
my kit I could not be rich how come
other people are widget I am NOT how
come they're successful and I'm not look
at the group's work on their roots if
you work on that long enough and you
give yourself live at a time eventually
you will have fruit that you want
now I have a special bonus clip from
Donald Trump on how to go against the
tide that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go watch the number one
what are the routes that you need to
work on number two how would you define
what you want and number three where do
you need to work smarter instead of
harder and if you made it this far in
the video I want to celebrate you give
me a hashtag believe down the comments
going against the tide is great if it
works now it doesn't always work and you
really have to be smart to go against
the tide because you're going against a
lot of smart people but when you get it
right
you'll end up better whether it's
Microsoft or Google I mean so many
people that have really hit big have
gone against the tide but you have to
have great confidence in yourself you
have to be the right person there are
very few people that can pull it off but
when you pull it off it's great
same thing in real estate you go against
the tide people are selling you're
buying the tide changes
if you want to know the easiest way to
become a millionaire check out their
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
time is your greatest friend here and if
you get in the game you're gonna win and
you need to get the game now not wait to
your business to success you have to own
assets